what's going on guys today we're talking
about a show that revived Christian
Slater's career that beat out Game of
Thrones for the golden globe yet still
remains a mystery to some it's mr. robot
and the new season premiered last night
and we're gonna hack into it with please
explain mr. robot breaking it down for
us we have the host of the new screen
junkies plus show debugging mr. robot
which you can see later on today the
premiere episode and then every Thursday
following the Wednesday night airing of
mr. robot she is the host of Collider
nightmares welcome Clark wolf also
screen junkies first-timer he is the
host of rob as a podcast Rob says
tornado so let's begin at the beginning
if you were going to describe the plot
of this show to someone what is mr.
robot I would say that mr. robot is a
show which really explores a side of
hacking about a very complicated
character named Elliot who is dealing
with a lot of stuff in his very
complicated hacking life and there is
also an evil corporation actually called
evil Corp well equality evil now one of
the things that's really intriguing
about this show is I can't remember
seeing anything quite like it on
television before can you talk to me
about that well the show does not have
any robots in it first of all this was
misleading to me no you're right we
haven't seen a show like this before
it's it's a real draw it's a drama that
not only deals with you know the hacking
world and real-life hackers and
corporations and things big business and
things like that but it also is looking
at this young man's mental health and
because he he clearly struggles with
some personal issues mental health
issues drug addiction if there's no
robots what does mr. robot mean what
does mr. robot mean to you in your own
words hmm
well mr. robot is a very important
figure in the universe of hacking which
Elliott ends up getting involved with
played by Christian Slater when I was
trying to describe this show to people I
would say it's a little bit like Fight
Club meets social network there have
also been comparisons to the the UK show
black mirror which I believe is
available on Netflix you talk to me
about that about technology's place
the only thing that I would say is that
it wouldn't come the black mirror
comparison
I feel like technology was used to teach
a lesson or a parable and I don't quite
think we've gotten there yet with
something like mr. robot but I think
that we could potentially get there with
some sort of lesson to be learned okay
so we've established that we have this
character Elliott he's our main hacker
and he's working with mr. robot to
basically hack into evil Corp now let's
talk some spoilers let's go a little bit
deeper yes there will be spoilers ahead
so Christian Slater
it's Elliott's dad that's partially the
reveal that mr. robot is actually
Elliott's that and the reason that this
is a surprise Elliott is twofold one as
far as his father is dead and also like
father is dead and he's a figment of
Elliott's imagination that was a pretty
big one absolutely that and there were
sort of allusions to that throughout the
season and then it kind of got cemented
for us but I I'm wondering for season
two looking ahead how this plays I
didn't have this loving embrace reaction
to it I kind of went wait a second whoa
and and so how are we compelled by
Christian Slater's performance or
character in the future knowing what we
know now I think that's gonna be really
interesting to see how that plays out
over season two he is becoming more
aware of this power that he has he was
mr. robot the whole time so how is
somebody who is essentially unraveling
before our eyes going to grapple with
the power and the relationships that
he's formed and what he's capable of
there's another character I want to ask
you about one of the former executives
at Corp tyrell wellick i think you're
supposed to hate him yeah he is somebody
who's very unlikable but by the time we
get to episode 10
he's mysteriously vanished and I think
that it brings up some really good
questions of where is he was he on board
with the hack that happened was he
trying to stop the hack that happened
and did Elliott stop him so entering
season two talk to us about where we
left off in the world and what the major
hack that went down accomplished they
wiped out all of the world's debt so
basically everyone is free nobody
is a slave to their debt anymore so that
was sort of the big plan from the people
in F society which is Elliot's group but
now there's a lot of now the NSA is
looking for the people responsible for
people are trying to undo it the heat is
going to be on Elliot here he was
basically an unknown so now that this is
like a worldwide manhunt for the people
that did this yeah well and that's a
bigger picture I you know synopsis but
on top of that you know Elliot I think
is really struggling with know did I do
the right thing I mean he sees the way
that average people are taking to the
streets and what they're actually doing
with this so-called freedom and I don't
think Elliot quite likes it
okay let me ask you one more question
would you recommend watching this show
to someone who's a little bit paranoid
already show it somebody's parent
already and exactly this is where you I
don't think this show is going to ease
anybody's fears about the internet or
they did you know it will stoke the
flames of your paranoia before we go
please tell us a little bit about your
show that you're gonna be hosting on
screen junkies plus debugging mr. robot
we're gonna be live on 4:00 p.m. Eastern
1 p.m. Pacific on Thursdays we're gonna
be very interactive taking tweed Skype
calls got a bunch of great guests lined
up for the season we're gonna be talking
to a hacker who's going to be talking to
us about some of the things that Elliott
is actually doing and whether or not
people in the real world are doing
things and it's gonna be Austin Spencer
Gilbert and talking through each one of
the episodes super cool any chance you
can get Edward Snowden as I guess we'll
work on it
great hey I'll take it have you seen mr.
robot are you looking forward to the new
season let us know in the comments
section we want to know and I want to
thank my guest
Clark Wolff thank you so much for being
here Rob cisternino
oh and one more thing are you going down
to San Diego next week for Comic Con you
are then you better come visit us at
screen junkies central we're gonna be
just a few blocks away and we're gonna
be doing so much cool stuff we're gonna
be doing live shows all throughout
comic-con and the tickets are free and
available right now
Woori can't be there we're gonna be
streaming the shows live also for free
to learn more about all this stuff free
tickets for the live shows and how to
watch the content go to screen junkies
comm slash central thank you for
watching I'm Hal Rudnick hit me up on
Twitter bye bye it's a show that you
really you could get done with it and
say but I need to go back and watch this
whole thing again and have a completely
different experience with the first
season so I think it really holds up in
in that level of that it has a real
rewatch ability yeah I think we all just
finished rewatching it like a few
minutes ago